Sorry sorry sorry no no no loop no looping around I think I was trying to put all my pins right here I'm like figuring this out right now Like wow Doesn't look that good.
I was like and I realize all my intro.
There's like a way to do this.
I how do I?
How do you oh my gosh?
I'm so bad at putting on accessories guys.
I'm not a not woman enough.
I
There's like a way...
How do I...
Put this behind my hair!
Okay, it's okay.
I'm trying to remember how.
I'm trying...
Oh, it's like that?
No, it was like...
No, now it's stuck on me.
Oh my gosh.
No, get this off of me.
Now it's stuck on me.
Get this off!
Get this off of me!
That kept moving!
I pinned it on my hair!
No!
Get this off of me!
Get this...
Get it off!
It's stuck on my hair!
I can't get it...
Let me...
Let me make sure you guys don't see this.
Real quick.
Oh my god!
How do I get this off?
No!
My immersion...
I can't...
I can't move it!
No!
I don't know how to use this.
I'm so dumb.
It's perfectly pinned on my head.
No!
It's part of me now.
Oh my god.
I can't get it off!
Wait, I got an idea.
I know what to do.
I'll get this off of me one way or another.
How do I get this off?
How do you...
How do you remove it?
Oh my god, it's like super glued to my head!
It's...
It's super glued to my head!
I can't remove it!
Okay, remove...
Okay, there we go.
There we go, that should be fine.
Now I'm okay.
I'm okay, guys.
I swear to god.
Everything is okay.
Everything is...
It's not okay, but everything is okay, guys.
I swear to god.
I'm gonna watch a tutorial real quick, guys.
Oh my god.
Palette to pin items behind layers We're doing it live.
Wait, what happened?
Why is there one of them?
What happened to the other one?
Wait!
What did I do?
Other one!
Oh my god!
I don't know what I did.
Guys, one of them is gone.
Oh my god.
Guys, I don't know what happened.
One of them disappeared.
What happened to it?
Okay, now I have one of them.
I think that's more manageable now.
I think.
Yeah, that's definitely more...
What happened to it?
Look, there's only one!
What happened to the other one?
What?
What happened?
I was watching my YouTube tutorial.
It just disappeared.
It just...
What happened to the other one?
Oh my god!
Okay, wait.
Let me finish watching this YouTube tutorial video.
Alright, let me make sure...
Chrome, you can't hear Chrome.
Oh, thank god.
Alright.
Alright, Miss VTuber.
That clearly has more experience than me.
Okay.
Okay, I just have to keep holding it.
I'm holding it.
This is a fucking liar!
She said if you keep holding it, a new window will pop up!
This fucking bitch.
She lied.
You must be like...
What the fuck is she talking about?
Okay, so...
Okay, so this cool...
Look, I'm trying to figure out how these VTubers do these cool dressing up things.
And I was like, oh my god.
I wanna be a cool VTuber.
You like that?
I have an ALR99 SMG right here.
I got...
I got a gun right here.
You guys like that?
Get rid of it!
I fucked up!
How do I get rid of it?
I just
got a gun.
Okay, let me figure out how to get rid of my gun real quick.
I...
No!
Okay, does it work if I just click the gun?
If I just click...
Guys, it's okay.
Happy Lunar New Year.
I know I'm late.
Oh my god.
What happened?
I'm trying to do something cool, but it's not happening right now.
It's not happening.
I've been trying to do something cool, but it ain't happening at the moment.
Stuff is not going as well as I would have liked it right now.
Well, the most disgusting of your first 12 months of monetization is it's literally the last one.
Anton, thank you for the magenta suit.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, look.
Okay, we're gonna figure this out together.
We are...
Okay, now there's like...
Now there's two.
How did I made it one?
What happened to the other?
Oh, no.
Now it's stuck on my head again.
Oh, fuck.
It's stuck in my... How did I do it?
I want one.
How did I do that?
There's so many things.
I don't know how I'm doing this.
Like...
How is there one?
Okay, now there's two again.
There's two.
They said if I hold it, a window will pop up.
It's lying to me.
How did I...
How did I get it to...
How did I made it one?
What did I do?
What did I...
At least...
At least the gun's gone.
At least I got the gun out of the way.
Wait, is it right click?
There's no way.
It's not right click.
I don't believe you.
There's no window popping out.
Okay, so like...
If you guys are wondering how people dress up their skin suits, like...
There's like this cool thing you can do that pops up a window where you can...
Where you can dress yourself up.
But then like...
Why is it not working?
Why is it...
But like, for some reason it's not working for me.
Like...
I did it before.
Like, I did it before.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna...
Like, I don't know what happened.
I don't know.
Like, I don't know what happened to me.
What happened?
Maybe you're just special.
But why doesn't it happen anymore?
I don't understand.
I don't...
Guys, I don't understand.
Why does it do this to me?
I...
Oh my god.
I just...
There's literally one instruction.
It's like click on the asset and hold it.
That's the most simple instruction I've ever heard.
No, I'm not married.
What the fuck are you talking about?
That's why I'll be single forever.
So I can farm red pockets for the rest of my life.
I'll be like 90 years old and I'll be like
And then I'll still get my red pocket money.
She's just like me.
I'll never have to give children red pocket money.
And I'll still farm it.
That's how...
How did I made it one?
Oh my god.
I'm gonna freak out.
I wanna do this.
I wanna dress up.
It's not fair.
Why can't I dress up as well?
I wanna dress up.
I don't understand.
Why won't you let me dress up?
Why won't you let me?
Why?
Let me be cute.
Dom, thank you for the magenta super.
Thank you.
Already a year?
It's so crazy to see you fly high like this.
Anyway, I wanna ask you to consider trying your head in a rap song.
You think you'll be able to just go with the flow?
I think you should since nothing can stop you at all.
Thank you for the magenta super.
Thank you.
I'm actually getting a rap song developed for an original song so like...
He just dropped that out of nowhere.
I give up.
I'm just gonna make it tiny.
Here we go.
Oh my gosh.
It's not even moving.
It's not even...
Like it's not the same.
I don't understand.
I wanna look cute.
It's not the same.
I don't understand.
Why won't you work?
Oh my god.
Nothing's working.
I got an idea.
Okay,
wait guys.
It's okay.
I'm okay.
I swear to god.
I'm okay guys.
I'm okay.
I know.
I have an idea.
Guys, I have an idea.
If this doesn't work, then I don't have ideas anymore.
I have an idea though.
Oh my god!
Does it only work in PNGs?
Are you Are you fucking kidding me?
Okay, I figured it out.
It doesn't pop up because I was literally... The item just doesn't work like that.
I...
I figured it out.
It literally doesn't work like that.
I...
It's cause the item was not... It only works on PNGs.
But how did I made it one?
How did I do that?
That like blew my mind.
How did I made you one?
You were two.
Like, I...
Oh, I figured it out.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I figured it out.
I'm gonna be so cute.
Everyone!
Everyone, I figured it out!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I'm gonna be cute.
Oh my god, I'm gonna be cute!
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay, I figured it out, everyone.
I figured it out, everyone.
Oh my god.
No, now you just gotta... Okay, guys.
Guys, give me a sec.
I'm working on it.
I'm gonna be cute now.
That's right.
Okay.
Right here.
Yay!
This is scuffed, but like...
Look at that!
Yay!
It doesn't look as good as I thought, but like...
At least I got it.
It's like little...
It's like little Mickey ears.
I figured it out!
I figured it!
I told you!
It works!
It's like little Mickey ears.
I fucking did it!
Oh my god.
Okay, I'll put it up here.
Oh wait, no, now it doesn't work anymore.
Why did I try to fix it?
Yay!
Oh my god!
I figured it out!
Yay!
Oh, it doesn't work as well.
Oh my god.
It does not work as well.
After like crashing out for a while, I just realized... Wait, wait.
Wait a minute, maybe I can fix this.
Okay.
Alright, come on, pop up.
Come on, pop up.
Oh, why did I...
Oh man, I should've...
Oh, I should've tested it out more before I...
Oh, whatever.
It's fine.
You know, I'll take this.
I'll take it.
Anton, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You look cute.
Thank you.
I worked so hard for this.
It's a little scuffed, but like, it's sort of working.
You see?
It sort of works.
You see that?
I can be cute just like all those other VTubers.
Look at...
I finally did it.
Alright, anyway, so I haven't... I really wanted to do this stream because I wasn't able to actually celebrate Lunar New Year with you guys.
And also, I wanted to show you guys stuff from photos and videos from Japan, from Sapporo.
I actually did not...
I didn't unpack my suitcase.
I might unpack it live and then show you guys some of the stuff I bought live and stuff.
That's how professional I am right now.
That's the degree of professionalism today.
I even set up an alarm at like...
I set up an alarm at like 11 AM today because I was like, oh, I gotta make sure.
I was like, haha, Doki, make sure you're prepared for today's stream.
I was like, oh, I'm so tired.
So I'll do it in the morning and then 11 AM and I was still really tired.
So then I was like, oh, that's alright.
I'll just wake up at...
Oh wait, no, I woke up at 10.
Yeah, 9 AM.
Actually, no, my alarm was at 9 AM.
And I was like, oh, I'm so tired.
I'll just wake up and I'll just sleep an extra hour.
Let me set up my alarm for another hour.
And then it was like 10 AM and I was like, oh, man, I'm still a little tired.
Maybe I'll just, you know what?
11, 11, 11 AM.
I can get everything done in an hour.
No, oh, in an hour and 30 minutes.
And then 11 AM, I was like, alright, I'm gonna get up.
I'm gonna take a shower and then I'm gonna take, unpack, and then clean up and then prep for today's stream.
And then I took a shower and then I went back to bed.
And I was like, maybe I'll sleep an extra, I'll just sleep an extra hour.
And then, and I was just like, and I woke up and then Doki Amber Doge was like, was like, WAKE UP!
I'M HUNGRY!
And then I was like, oh, fuck, okay, you're right.
And then I fed him and he was like, oh, you think it's over?
IT'S WALKIES TIME!
YOU THINK IT'S OVER NOW THAT YOU FED ME?
DON'T YOU DARE GO BACK TO THE BED!
I NEED MY WALKIES NOW!
And then I was like, oh, fuck, okay, I have 30 minutes till stream, so like, that means I have 10 minutes till stream cause like, I need to walk.
Doki Amber Doge, I need to walk dad, and I came back and I was like, wait, I didn't even set up anything for the stream.
I was like, wait a minute, I didn't even set up anything for the stream!
So from 9am to like 12, 20pm I was not existing.
I did not exist at all.
Um, yeah, walkies are non-negotiable at all.
So yeah, so that was basically my morning.
But I did send all the pictures and videos to my Discord server so I could like, pull them.
I didn't even save them, by the way.
I just literally was just sending them from my phone to my PC and be like, bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu.
So, um, so we'll get to that soon.
Um, anyway, but yeah, happy Lunar New Year!
Uh, something Fai La.
Like, I haven't spoken Cantonese in so long because like, you know, um, yeah, there's like, it's so, you know, I live in Canada.
There's not, I mean, to be fair, I do sometimes speak Cantonese if I'm like, at a, um, at like a Cantonese restaurant or something.
And then I'll be like, oh, you go, you go, you go, you go, you go.
But go, but go there.
I feel like I have a bigger accent now because I haven't spoken it in a long time.
And so like, I feel like my accent now for Cantonese is a lot more.
It's a lot worse.
Just cause like, um, uh, uh, just cause like, you know, I haven't said, like, spoken the language in so long.
So, uh, but go, uh, Sun Ling Fai La, Dai Ga Dai Lei, Sun Tai Kien Hon, Gong Hei Fat Choy.
Gong Xi Gong Xi Gong Xi Ni, Ah Gong Xi Gong Xi Gong Xi Ni.
Woah!
Uh, but yeah, hope you guys, I really wanted to celebrate it early, but like I said, I was on vacation.
Uh, when Lunar New Year came, uh, like, started.
Uh, and, uh, and so like, it's been like, I don't know, like, it's been a mess.
Hahahaha.
The start of the Year of the Snake Has not been the best for me.
Not gonna lie.
I've been like sort of incredibly unlucky so far So I hope it gets better I hope okay.
So like when I came back from japan um I found out so I thought like my lips I thought remember I told you guys that my skin got felt scraped and everything So I don't think it was from blowing my nose I think when I came back from japan my skin around my mouth just exploded or something due to the change of like Atmosphere,
I don't know something was wrong because like when I came back like the my my lips Like the skin was just peeling off and then the around the mouth too like and then I was like Oh, maybe it's because I was I was like scraping it with sandpaper when I was blowing my nose but then like But then I was like,
no, this is weird.
This is Lips on my skin are like falling off and I was like this is weird
This is this is not okay, so I bought like those like, um lip balm um I like I bought like lip balm and like those like healing lip balm and stuff to like fix my lips and lotion for my mouth, yeah, I was like I feel like and then like the next couple of days like,
uh, my lips just like Uh, just like the the skin on my lips just slowly kept peeling off like and off and I was just like, oh man man This month has been pretty fucked up I was like, I was like, oh, okay Yeah, yeah So like yeah, so like day by day like my the skin on my lips just kept peeling off more and more Like just until all the I guess the dead skin was gone and but it was so annoying because like,
you know, like you can feel it just Attached to your lips, but you can't do anything about it because you don't want to force it You don't want to force it off.
So like you just have to wait until it like naturally peels off and everything so then I was just like Ah, this is thank god.
I don't thank god.
I'm not going outside But the thing is but because my lips were like, you know in danger, you know um I got a little like bump on like a little like because like I guess like I think that's what happened.
Like one of them I accidentally peeled off So like they're like my top upper lip.
There's like a little bump like a little like wound there like I don't know what it's called, but like it's Is that blister?
I don't fucking know.
I've never had by the way This has never happened to me before like literally I got it off first.
Um, I got it off first.
Uh, After after coming back from my vacation.
So that's why I was like this month has been pretty fucked so like I have like this little bump that like, you know, you can tell there's like a wound there because it's like, uh, like a little red wound thing there and then It's very annoying.
Like it doesn't hurt.
It's just very annoying And yeah, so because like I believe i'm pretty sure like some bacteria But sorry, I shouldn't be guys.
You must be like i'm eating right now.
Why you yeah, maybe a scab Yeah, I have a little scab on the top left.
Um, so yeah, it's great.
I I'm having a great time.
By the way I i'm still recovering from my cold as you guys can hear from my coughs.
Um, So, all right, this is recap on what happened to me during my vacation um I got food poisoning Um, I got a cold on the last day before I left japan
Um I I uh My finger got infection for like four to four days and then it healed when I left japan
Okay, it keeps going by the way it keeps my lips exploded when I returned home
That fucking happened Uh Um and then like what I didn't tell you guys, okay, this is a story I didn't tell you guys but Um uh when I was in japan, I was so fucking stupid because I Forgot that I didn't realize because I thought I had so much stuff going on but like I forgot that uh I booked the hotel Uh until like the 30th or the 30.
Yeah, I forgot I booked the hotel until the 30th and the thing is I forgot about it because you know algs was there so every so like the 31st the 1st was like fully booked by everywhere and I was like next to the I was like, um, I was at the like like the the like algs area too So like I forgot about that so my regular room my regular room it was um I couldn't book any more rooms in that hotel anymore.
And do you know what room they had left?
the most expensive suite And then all the surrounding hotels were fully booked so I was like, oh fuck what So for two nights I stayed in the most expensive suite They had And oh my god.
Oh, i'm not going on vacation for a while.
By the way.
I Because I was like, oh my god Well, it was not worth it I let you guys know right now I I felt like oh my god, but she treated like royalty.
That's a fucking lie I was not treated.
I thought okay, so Um, there was no jikku.
Okay, it looked it was okay I forgot to take pictures of the suite itself because like I was I was not in a good mood So So by the way, i'm not going on vacation for a very fucking long time after that I spent way I spent way too much money in in japan.
Like this has been I I was burning money.
I was like I was like anyway, um Anyway, so there was no hotels left like there wasn't any hotels at all Like that has free vacancy and then I for the for like 31st of first I had to book the suite and like the thing is I booked my for the hotel like Months in advance,
by the way, I booked it, but I don't think but because I booked it months in advance I didn't I didn't realize 30th like I forgot 31st of first And mgs ends on the second and she has ends on the second so um Anyway, so why did I say it wasn't worth it?
Well On the day on one of the days I got to stay at the suite I got food poisoning
I got food poisoning And then so like obviously I couldn't go outside You know because I was not a person anymore and then So I was like, I need a- I couldn't put food down in my stomach.
So I- so like, you know, I was in the suite, this giant-ass suite with like a living room, a fucking dining room.
The bar, like you can basically like the little like- oh, what is it called?
The little refrigerator where you can like- you could actually drink anything in there.
And then- and then like the- the giant-ass bed, and then like there's like- there's like two bathrooms, and like a giant fucking bathroom- like a shower, a minibar.
Yeah, so in the suite, the minibar is free, so you can literally just drink whatever the fuck you want in the minibar.
Anyway, that- that part doesn't matter.
So, you know, thinking I bought the most expensive suite, I'd be treated like royalty, right?
Like, you think that, you know, if anything, they'll treat you fucking well, because you're like, oh my god, she's in the suite.
Well- okay, I need to blow- I need to sneeze.
Okay, I made it myself.
Okay, anyway, I called the front desk, and I was like, Hello, can you buy me medicine?
I'm not okay right now.
Can you- Can you buy me medicine?
I- I have food poisoning.
I can't go out.
And then the front desk was like, Sorry, ma'am.
We don't offer these services.
And then I literally was like, we cannot buy you medicine.
My reply was- I was like, okay, I guess I die?
I- I
- I- I just couldn't believe she said that!
I literally replied that back!
I was like, I guess I die?
I guess I- I can't go out.
I'm so dumb.
I'm sick.
I was like- I just couldn't believe she said that to me!
I was like- I was literally dying!
I was literally- not literally.
I was like, I was not a person.
I was not even a person anymore.
I couldn't- I couldn't believe it!
I didn't- I didn't grab tissue boxes because I used up all my tissues.
I'll be right back.
I'm back.
I ran- oh my god.
Thank you, Cactus, for pinning that message.
I forgot to show.
But yes, I do have a pajama collection right now that you can grab.
But yes.
No, I did not get my medicine in the end.
I was- I guess I- I- I can't believe- I can't- I was like- I spent so much on literally your most expensive hotel room and you can't even go- by the way, there was a- there was a fucking Lawson right down the street.
I was like, you can't even go to the Lawsons for me?
You- it's five minutes.
It's- if I wasn't like, chained to my bathroom, I would go to the Lawson.
Like, I couldn't- I was like, I couldn't believe it.
I- It's a liability?
If I died in their hotel room, it would have been a liability regardless.
Oh my god.
Anyway, um.
I was not- I told you, I was not a bath- I was not like, a person anymore.
They didn't even- I didn't even realize you could make it!
Apparently, you can!
Oh my god.
Oh, I would haunt this hotel.
I would haunt it.
Oh my god.
I didn't know they can offer to call a doctor, because they didn't offer it!
I- they didn't even- they didn't even offer it!
I didn't realize that was an option!
I didn't realize!
Because I was never offered this option!
I- anyway, so like, you know, later on in the night, I was like, oh man, you know what?
Apparently, I should- I really- I should try and get something in my stomach.
And then, um.
Um, and then so I called room service, and I was like, can I have a banana?
Like, I legitimately- That's all.
I was like, I need a banana.
I need something in my stomach.
I- I need something.
And then they're like, okay, we'll get you a banana.
And then they called back, and was like, sorry ma'am, we don't have any bananas for room service.
Like, we- And I was- they're like, we can't offer you a banana.
I was like, I just wanted one thing.
I- Go- just go to the losses and buy me a banana at that point!
Like, just- I just- they're like, we can offer you kiwi, and um, I don't fucking know what the other one- Strawberries.
And I'm like, oh yeah, let me just fucking get an allergic reaction and end this all.
And it-
I was just like- I was like, oh my god.
They have like, all these cantaloupes.
They have cantaloupes, they have kiwis, they have strawberries, but they don't even have a fucking banana.
I was so sad.
Oh my god, I was so sad.
Yeah, I toughened it out.
I- Um, I like- so like, I had no meds.
I had um, luckily I- Pocari Sweat, luckily in my fucking mini bar.
I had- I had Pocari Sweat in my fucking mini bar, so there was that.
So like, I basically survived my food poisoning with like, Pocari Sweat and water.
And then just being chained to my bathroom.
I just- I just- I had no medicine, no bananas.
I just fucking- I fucking went in I went in the hardest way possible.
Oh my god.
Anyway, that's how- Wow, what a vacation, Turkey.
Oh my god, wow.
Oh my god.
Yeah, no, I was- I was- It was not okay.
I was not okay that day.
The day after, I felt a lot better.
I don't know.
I think I like- because like, I basically like, just went, okay body, give me the worst thing.
Give me like, the- Like, just get everything out like, in one day.
Like, I don't- I don't care anymore.
Just get everything out.
And then the next day, I ate carbonara spaghetti.
I was like, I'm feeling invincible.
Ball!
So, you guys remember that?
I literally just went and ate fucking carbonara spaghetti right after.
Oh, I have photo of that carbonara spaghetti too.
Let me grab it real quick.
Let me- Okay, let me see it.
Let me grab it.
I'll grab my- I didn't- Guys, I need you guys to know, I didn't even edit these photos.
I usually put like, filters and stuff to be like, oh, look how pretty the- I don't have time to put filters on these photos.
We're going straight into like, unfiltered photos.
No like, no like, cute filters to make the colors pop up more.
This is basically- This was the pasta I ate post food poisoning, which is the day after.
The day after I was throwing up and also other things in the bathroom, I went straight for this pasta.
You should- I did and I was okay.
That was so risky.
It's all right.
It was- I- It was the risk I was willing to take.
It was- I was like, I was like, I'm ready.
I'm ready.
I'm fucking ready.
I already went through so much the last- the last day.
And it worked.
I was okay.
I was okay in the end.
Also, also you guys didn't know, um, uh, Jack, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
How do you not play a tank in Rivals?
Because I already had to tank life.
I- I already had to go through life and tank it.
Why do I have to put myself through that in the virtual world?
And the virtual world is my escape from tanking.
Like, what do you mean?
I'm here to escape the- the tanking of life.
I'm not here to fucking do this all over again.
I- Hahahahaha!
Uh, all right, anyway, uh...
Anyway, oh yeah, speaking of like, Marvel Rivals.
Quick update.
So you know, I've been part of this the VTuber- Now there's a VTuber Marvel Rivals tournament.
So, um, we're technically allowed one non-VTuber.
So, like obviously and like two GM- like two GM, uh, plus players.
So like obviously I'm one of the GM plus players because I'm one above all so the second person I got was super Gomez Because we needed a DPS player and then like Gomez is like, you know known as like one of the best DPS players in the world and so but But Kony's in it too
How the fuck did you get Kony in as a VTuber So Kony is Categorized as a VTuber on my team and you guys want to know how?
It's because It's because during the very first SageM Slam He used a Mickey Mouse VTuber VTuber model on stream so it Counted and I asked because the staff was like if as long as he's used a PNT or a VTuber model before 2025 it counts and then I asked Kony,
I was like Kony do you want to join this this VTuber Marble Raven Tournament Like this Marble Raven Tournament and Kony was like the VTuber one Oh my god, I'll be so fucking funny
Okay, but there is a catch have you ever used a VTuber model and he linked me this video
The staff like the staff I was like you said he used it for this is that count and they're like, yes, it's approved So that's that's how that's how Kony is categorized as a VTuber on my team
I Asked I asked permission.
It's not like I fucking sneaked in there and be like he VTuber it comes the joy I asked permission.
I They said yes, so it's not my fault I
Anyway, anyway, anyway, so we're just missing one more tank player for day one I won't say we have a tank player for day two We have to take place for day two.
So we just miss but like for day we need one tank player So the rest of my team is okay.
So it's me Gomez Kony Shoto and limo and We're just missing one more tank player and We have somebody on day two, but it's not fully confirmed yet so we're just waiting for We're just waiting for like confirmation on their side on whether or not they can they they want to join day two But like they gotta wait for further confirmation Because it's not up to them
I Was told that day one's gonna be super easy and in day two is where it was the final so it's where like It's where like things get like actual rough So we just need so many to be there for your temporary sub as day one.
So that's the update Um, that's the update for the rivals tournament.
Oh my god.
It's so cute My little like it's like little pom-poms on my head.
See it was worth it It was so worth it that fucking 20-minute crash.
I'm trying to make this work.
It was so cute.
These are oh my god They're so cute It was worth the 20 minutes of fucking crashing out on stream trying to get this to work Darkblade, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Happy Lunar New Year Doki You need to understand you're crashing on just one of the many cute things about you.
Thank you for the super chat Darkblade Thank you.
Thank you.
Um Simple mind is they give us a super chat.
Thank you Doki You wonder why dad's having an affair with the dog sitter?
You're eating carbonara while he's eating stale dog food Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you
Didn't know Okay
Now I know dry dog food can't go stale Just I don't know why it just never occurred to me that dry food can go stale I just never occurred to me Cranberry, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Happy nesticle day where we finally got named Thank you for the super chat.
All right.
What are you?
What else I want to tell you guys about?
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Let me know there's something else.
I wanted to I had something else I want to talk about but I already forgot Oh, yeah, I might as well show you guys some of the photos.
Let me grab some photos okay, so Oh Man look at this.
I went to an arcade.
I went to an arcade and then they had
But let me check if there's okay need to make sure there's no reflection cuz like I said, I did not check anything
Yeah, I went to an arcade and like this is like the I had to take a picture of this I found minecraft dungeons
Oh My god, I was just not expecting it like I legitimately you know see these people in the background of the famous like those like like those like rhythm games and stuff like And I was like and then there's like and then there's fucking Minecraft dungeons Doing here Just doing here my Japanese arcade.
I was not I was not expecting that so sorry I just I had to show that out of all the photos I took I had to show that oh my god So I took a lot of photos of like, you know My adventures in Japan and then I brought my you know, I brought like a mini Doki plushie with me.
So like look at that.
Look at that.
I'm here, too This is like my fruit like time.
I ate ramen So like I brought her I brought her along retro Doki along with me for some photo shoots I try to be super sneaky because I'll show you why I try to be super sneaky Some of some of these photos are like incredibly dangerous What do you mean by Incredibly dangerous Doki so like,
um, so what are these instances was that?
Where is this might you ask this is the ALGS player lounge
They don't know
Sneaked you guys in to the ALGS official player lounge and then I I legitimately I got up this I got a dragoon for like five seconds and was like
My bag, it's so like I sneak just and I sneak both of us into the player By The way, you see the top left that's super blurry.
That's where Timmy was sitting.
That's
That's where he was sitting on it on the left side so you guys are so close to Timmy
That's out
Me and Timmy in my one photo Anyway, um But yes, that was how I really don't suspicious There that was how how dangerous I was playing the game So close yet so far.
I told you it was dangerous This Ruining everything Oh, yeah, and also also, okay, so I also had a conveyor belt sushi By the way, I waited an hour plus for this goddamn fucking conveyor belt sushi because like it was literally like the only It was the only Restaurant there that had so many people lining up for it.
Like when I got the When I got the number The number was that like, oh wait, give me a sec Okay.
Yeah, it's fine.
Okay.
I was like wait, there's a reflection
It's fine there's nothing there so so So when I got the number I was at okay I even took a picture of the number I had but I'm not I was my number was 213 that was my number that was My number was 213 and then they called out they were guess what number they were at a hundred and fifty five
155 and I was that too.
I waited I didn't care I was like at that point in my life.
I was eating konbini stuff So like cuz like I never I was I too tired.
I think it was like day two or three It was day two.
So like oh day.
Yeah day two So like for the first day I had like konbini food because there was no time to get actual food And I was so tired after it like the games and stuff So like and then dinner time was gonna be the first time I actually got to eat real food on day two It's literally lunch dinner first day and then lunch was just konbini and I was like,
I don't care I will wait for the rest of my life for like actual real food I was like konbini food is good.
It's real good.
But like it's it's not like a restaurant, you know It's still it's still not a restaurant food you can see it is good But like I could be eating at a restaurant, you know Like I don't want to spend my vacation Just eating like it's stuff I buy at Lawson's like I don't want it.
I don't want it like to have that as my vacation so So I was just like I was like, I don't care how many hours I have to wait.
I don't fucking I'm gonna get real food I can't go back to Lawson's.
I can't go back
I Had a lot of egg sandwiches That was like the one thing that really like I was like, I mean like I need eggs Okay.
Also, let me show you guys.
I Okay When I went shopping I Okay
Don't judge me too hard.
So I was at a market I was at a market and then so you guys see something there.
That's a little silly you guys see something Silly I saw I saw like
Oh My god,
oh my I just I don't know I just I the idea that I could make um Cookies was like I I never made a sugar cookie before it but like I'm gonna learn
Also, I was like, okay you see like these wedding arches I was just gonna put my stuff So, um at this market they had like a whole row Dedicated to like, you know, like there's like oh she Stands and stuff like um, like the like folders and like ways to display your oh She and stuff like that.
So like one of them was like a wedding arch and I was like, I'm buying that for myself I'm fine, but my own doki shrine so like stuff you can do for your shrine I was like, I'm buying that will put two doki's under there.
Like who what better way what better person to marry than yourself?
You know
I Was like tokyo's turkey self no, yeah, exactly I bought like stuff.
Oh my I bought a lot of random shit.
Like I was like I was going fucking wild like I Bought a lot of stuff.
That's just like I'm gonna put this on myself All right, whatever stuff whatever stuff can't show you guys from my photos.
I have a lot of food.
Oh, yeah here There's another one of like taking some of the most risky photos I've ever taken
Looking around and be like, is there anybody watching and then I was like
Risky photos of my life is a walking Making sure nobody is watching Me That's me, oh my god, that's me right there Wow
And but Snowed a lot It's snowed way too much.
I was not used to it.
I wasn't I I was not used to the snow at all like I just I guess mostly cuz when it's snowing When it's snowing, I'm usually inside So like being outside when it's snowing has been like really rough for me cuz I'm like, this is what I've been trying to avoid oh,
I'm sorry, okay, I Also took a photo of this because I was like, I'm special
This is what you don't see oh Yeah, that's right the media creator and partners lounge Wow, that's right.
I've got all the I got these cars so I could go Yeah,
um So like okay funny story Okay, so like obviously I okay I'd spend more money going coming back cuz I spent you know I was like I need to have a good trip.
I need a fly business class back Because like I obviously I was like struggling and I was like at best, you know I want to have a good flight back as well, you know, so And then what I forgot was that You know, I like to be with the people
So like so like when you you know when you're going through like customs and stuff When you're going through the customs, you know, I Forgot that.
Okay.
So I was lining up for the customs and stuff to you know To go through the airport to go through the terminal and then when I showed the guy When you before you go through the customs area you have to show a guy your ticket They saw my ticket is business class and then he was like you're not supposed to line up here I was like,
huh?
Like here we're gonna take you to the business class line And I legit we T took me to the line next door where it was like obviously it was empty You know cuz like we get the fast pass we
So like, you know, he took me it was just next door and he was like
Cuz like I was like I was like in a car with my friend and cuz I was just like I Guess like just like talking about my adventure in Japan and then I was in the car with my friend and then I was like oh my god, I forgot I'm special and The guy next to me another business class guy next to me like laughed at that because I said Wow,
I was like like like beeping my dick.
Yeah.
I was like, oh my god.
I forgot I'm special
I Was going through the business class
Story is out of my tax bracket.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you
Oh Yeah Here's another and lucky part.
So like I forgot about this part of my how lucky I've been this month I forgot to mention this.
So, you know on my flight return back to Canada.
Um, I have to fly to Tokyo first because there's no direct flight to Canada So I have to fly back to Tokyo first so and then fly straight back to Canada, but the thing is
So when I was checking in the lady was like Oh the flight that you're supposed to be on might be delayed So you might not be able to catch your transfer flight in time.
I was like, oh no What do we do and she was like I'm gonna put you on the earlier flight though a flight that departs like in 20 minutes like 20 in the 25 minutes.
I was like, okay, that seems right.
All right Yeah, that should be good.
And then so so, um So, you know, obviously I said, yeah sure.
I don't want to miss my transfer and then I Waited and the flight that they put me on Got delayed and the flight I was originally gonna be on didn't get delayed so both flights Boarded at the same time
Because the flight I booked they transferred me to earlier got delayed, and then they both arrived at the same time.
They both arrived at the same time.
And you know what's worse?
I should have checked my flight hours, but when I arrived, I had a 3 plus hour layover.
So in my head, I was like, what the fuck did this bitch mean when she said I was gonna miss my transfer?
I was like, in what world would I miss my transfer?
In what fucking world?
I was like...
So I just, I waited at the airport for 3 plus hours waiting for my next flight.
I was just like, are you, are you fucking kidding me?
I was so, I was so done.
I was so fucking done.
I was so, I was so, I was so over.
Oh my god.
Anyways, so yeah, that was, that was basically how, how unlucky I was during that.
I'm pretty sure there were more lucky stories.
I swear, I was writing this stuff down, and I was like, Jesus fucking Christ, like how, how much worse can it go?
Oh my god.
It was like almost 4 hours.
It wasn't, it was like a 3 to, it was like 3 hours and like 30 minutes layover.
And I was just like, what the fuck do I do?
What do I do?
I, oh my god.
But the fact that she was like, you will miss your transfer if you, you know.
I was like, I got there, and I was like waiting almost 4 hours for my next flight.
I'm just like, how would I miss my transfer?
How in what, in what world would I consider, be considered missing this goddamn transfer?
Oh my god.
Okay, yeah, so yeah, that was, that was my flight back.
That was what happens.
In my flight back.
Um, oh yeah, oh yeah, another thing.
They gave me the wrong laundry too.
Cause like, you know, so my benefits with the suite is, I still have to pay for laundry.
But like, they are willing to, um, if you're like a regular fucking person apparently at the hotel.
You have a timeline, which is basically like you can't, they won't do your laundry after 10am.
So like, I was like, oh, can I hand you my laundry?
And then like, you give it back to me the next day.
And they're like, yeah, we can do that.
Cause they're like, um, at least they gave me that privilege, you know.
Cause when I was like a regular person at the hotel, I was like, can you pick up my laundry?
And they're like, it's after 10am.
I'm sorry, it's closed.
But like, you know, after I got the suite, I was like, can you pick up my laundry?
And they're like, of course, but we'll only be able to give it back to you tomorrow.
Is that okay?
And I was like, wow, the difference in like what money saves.
Like, wow,
that, what a difference.
How they treat you, I guess.
And the difference in status.
Anyway, um, um, so, so basically, uh, you know, I, I, I gave them my laundry.
And then when I got it back, they gave me men's laundry.
I was like, I was like, wait, I don't wait.
What the fuck?
I was like, there's like these like jeans.
There's like men jeans and like, um, and there's like, some of them was mine.
Like half the laundry was mine.
And then they gave me like men jeans and like pants.
And like, I was like, you know what was missing?
My underwear.
I was like, where's my underwear?
And like my pants.
I was like, I was like, oh my God.
Why do you have men jeans?
And I called and I was like, hi, I'm, I'm missing my laundry.
And you gave me wrong laundry.
And then like, and then they're like, oh my God, I'm so sorry.
Like, and they're like, what are you missing?
I was like, my underwear.
And then like, and then obviously they gave me my right laundry after that.
But I was like, how, how, I'm just one, like, I'm clearly like, like how did you give me a, half my laundry was there.
Half of them was there.
But then for some reason, like my underwear wasn't.
And I was like, oh my God.
How did they fuck that up?
Oh my God.
Anyway, I got everything back.
Guys, I got, I got everything back.
And then the laundry ladies were like super apologetic.
It was like, you got everything?
I was like, yeah, I got, I got everything.
Anyway, also like, I feel like it's so, it was so wasteful because they like, they pack every individual clothing.
And I like their own little plastic bag.
So like, it just, it felt weird for me.
Like every individual clothing was just in within its own little plastic bag.
Like those clear plastic bags and stuff.
And, and that's just, you have to like open it and be like, all right, this is mine.
All right.
So yeah, that was, that was my experience.
I don't know.
Maybe I have more lucky stories.
But like, it, you know, it was just not going the way of, my year of the snake did not start out that well.
Jane, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Late, late Licey for you.
Snuck this in at work, so I'll watch bot later.
Don't tell my boss.
Don't worry, snitches get stitches, guys.
We don't, just like how you didn't snitch on me.
Okay.
Nobody snitched on me to my manager.
But then he noticed, he was like, oh, hey, instantly sold out.
And then he was like, but you lowered the price.
I was like, no, it was just fun.
We just thought it was really funny.
We just, we thought, we thought it was really funny.
It was like, it was like, oh, hey, congratulations, you sold out, but you lowered the price.
Anyway, um, there's only he he ha ha.
It was for the bid.
I did.
I got him to Celestio, so he's happy now.
I got him to Celestio.
He's less angry at me.
Gladstone, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki actually got visited by the bad memes.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Darkblade, thank you for the super chat.
Chat, she's gonna forget about the cookie cutters.
And that's not true.
That's not true.
It's so funny.
I want to make Buddha cookies.
It's so cool.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Manny, did you get, yeah, I got him.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, let's see.
Let me see what other photos I can show you.
I have so many photos.
I'm just, like, thinking about which one to show you guys, like, next.
Let's see.
Oh, yeah.
They had, like, a live replica.
By the way, I'm gonna be checking...
I have the schedule finalized for this week.
But look, look.
Look at that.
The supply bin.
Apparently, you can open them, but I didn't open them.
Because I didn't realize you could open them until I saw a video of it.
But here's the supply bin.
Look at that.
And there's me right there.
It was so cool.
Like, the whole fan area was really cool.
Wait, what was I gonna say before?
What was I gonna say?
I wanted to say something.
Fuck.
There was something I wanted to talk about, but I forgot what it was.
What was I talking about before?
The supply bin.
Oh, yeah, Apex.
I made the schedule.
I made...
I finished the schedule.
I just got tired and didn't put it on the graphic.
But tomorrow, we're checking out the new Apex season.
And we're gonna have a member stream, too.
Apparently, if you guys didn't know...
I know, it's been a while since I talked about Apex.
Like, because, you know, Apex hasn't been doing so well lately.
But...
Apparently, they changed a lot for the new season.
As in, they removed helmets.
And then they put out, like...
These, like, bins where you can grab guns and attachments.
So, yeah, we're gonna be checking out the new seasons and seeing how that's gonna be like.
And then...
This week is Dad's birthday!
Another celebration!
I have something planned.
Something special planned for Dad's birthday.
So, Doki Amber Doge birthday.
So, the hashtag would be...
HBDAmber2025.
So, yes, it's his birthday!
On February 14th!
That's the only thing we're celebrating.
Because that's the most important day.
Guys, nothing else!
That's the most important day!
There's nothing else to celebrate!
Because it's his birthday!
So, on the 14th.
This week.
Nothing else is important!
So...
What do you mean?
Do you hate Dad?
Do you hate him?
Do you hate this?
Say that to his face!
Right now!
Oh, wait.
Oh, wait, I don't have it on.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Give me a sec.
Alright.
I'm gonna bring him over.
Just so you can look at his face.
And tell me that you hate him.
Alright, alright.
Say that to his face right now!
Do you hate him?
The 14th is a very special day for him.
Hey, man!
Are you trying to say it's not important?
The 14th?
That's right!
It's a special day!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I hate you, Dad!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm going on a date with every Dragoon that they've all tried to make.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
MrBrokenBond, thank you for the super chat.
At least I know I'm free that day.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Dynasty Warriors Origin on Saturday.
Oh, yeah!
If you are a member, goon.
The Valentine's...
Sorry.
What is Valentine's?
But...
The February wallpaper is the only way you can celebrate Valentine's Day.
No, what?
You mean Dad's birthday?
Sorry, Dad's birthday wallpaper will be out maybe today or tomorrow.
It depends if I'm lazy or not.
Anyway, so I sent the...
I have the actual illustration and I sent the concept art of the outfit.
So, this is my birthday.
This is my birthday outfit for Dad, okay?
So, this would be the member's wallpaper.
So, if you are a member, goon.
If you are a member, goon, you will be able to receive the February's wallpaper.
Yay!
Yeah.
So, that's just gonna give you guys the sneak peek for February's wallpaper.
Is that Mint's sock?
Is it actually?
I just let the artists do whatever the fuck they want.
I was like, you can design the outfit.
I think it's just subconscious.
Rio, welcome to the tomato farm!
Welcome, welcome!
Alright, let me show more photos.
Let me show you guys.
I have like a lot more photos to show you guys.
Oh yeah, there was like...
Okay, let me see.
Oh wait, do I have the photo of the line?
Wait, I need to show you guys the Timmy line.
I need to show you guys...
Wait, I'm not gonna... I'm gonna be like buffering for a sec cause I need to...
I need to show you guys how long...
This is a very important photo cause I think it's fucking hilarious how long the Timmy line was.
I...
I was just... I was looking at the Timmy line.
I was taking photos of it.
I was like, that's a really fucking long line.
Alright, I think it's this, right?
Okay.
Wait, did I send everything?
Or like, something like didn't send... I did, okay.
Alright.
Let me make sure like nothing is showing.
Okay, so like, let me show you the Timmy line and how...
By the way, this photo should have been four sets of photos, but I made it three because I couldn't be bothered to take the fourth part of the line.
Cause that was... It was a long line.
It was...
It was a very, very... I was like...
The thing is, he wasn't even playing.
That's the thing.
He wasn't even like playing in the...
In the finals.
But he like went to do like a photo shoot for it.
And I was just like, oh my god.
Like...
That was crazy.
I did not realize how famous he was in Japan.
I did not realize this.
I just need you... I just want you guys to see how long this line is.
Like, I'll show you... There's a fourth...
There should be a fourth set, but I just didn't bother taking the fourth set.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thanks for the year, Doki.
My birthday is tomorrow but I'll be working and not able to catch the stream.
Can I get an early happy birthday?
Of course!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Deadpool.
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
Mr. Stan, thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you, thank you.
Dad, here's some cash for you to get fresh treats.
Just don't tell Doki about what's that supposed to mean.
Alright, here we go.
I'll show you guys.
This is gonna be an adventure.
So, this is line one.
There he is.
I sneaked a photo of him.
I'm not a fucking stalker.
Alright.
Woah!
Okay.
Okay, let me grab...
Here's...
Okay.
Here's line two.
So you can see it starts... There you go.
It starts going... There's the line.
It's going this way.
And then let me show you line three.
Where...
And then... And then line three.
This is how far it went.
There's a fourth part too to this line, but I couldn't be bothered.
It was just too much.
And there's line...
There's part three of that line.
So, it was like...
It was just to meet Timmy.
It was just...
It was just... There's a fourth part.
There was more to this line.
It was like...
It went far.
I was not expecting how far that line was.
Yeah.
And then... Okay.
You want real stalker-ish?
So you remember how I was like...
To like... Because like Effect wanted to meet up.
And... I wanted to do a little joke where I was like... I meet up with Effect.
And then I don't tell him it's me.
And then I...
Because he was... Him and Alliance were doing an unofficial meet and greet.
And then obviously he gave me the wrong information.
I talked about this before.
So then I was like...
I legitimately... I gave up because like... This is actual.
I'm not a stalker.
I swear to God.
So like... I like gave up.
I gave up and just took a picture of him in the back.
And then sent that to him.
And I walked off.
I was like...
You missed your chance.
And he's like... No!
I love how someone in my chat was like... When the fan...
When the idol has to...
Can't meet the fan because he's too popular.
So...
There's him in that blue jacket.
That's him in the blue jacket.
And then... That's a lie.
Do you see how... Do you see the line?
I was not lining up for that.
I was...
I was not... So that blue jacket...
That's a fact.
And I was not lining up for that.
I was like... This is...
It's cold.
It's so fucking cold.
And I was like...
For fuck... And I just literally...
And then I left.
I left after that.
I'm not a stalker.
I'm not...
By the way, I'm not lining up.
You're right.
Lining up to meet someone that wants to meet me?
I am not lining up for that shit.
I'm not...
I'm not lining up for someone that wants to meet me.
But I am not a stalker.
I did.
I just took one...
I took one photo.
You can't categorize me as a stalker after one photo.
I'll show you guys more aquarium photos.
But I was like...
I felt so...
I wasn't embarrassed at that time.
But I was a terrorizer at the aquarium because I was so loud.
Because everybody else was quiet.
It was so serene.
They're all enjoying the atmosphere.
And I'll be like...
Oh my god!
Look at you!
Look at these guys.
Oh my god.
I love these guys because it was so funny because you see that guy that shrunk down?
I walked over and then he was like...
He retracted himself.
Sorry.
It happens like that when I get nervous.
So you can see this guy.
His whole head is out.
And then he walked up and then this tiny guy with a little head up there.
He's like...
I was just like...
It's so cute.
I'm a menace.
I'm a menace to society.
But oh my god.
They were so cute.
And then there was like...
I had my whole nature documentary set where I was just recording.
I'm doing dumb ass fucking commentary.
Oh yeah!
Let me show you how...
Okay.
Let me see if I can get the video.
Let me see.
You might be hearing...
I just want to show you guys how fucking packed... Okay.
This one.
This would be a good video to show you guys.
So...
Uh...
Oh my god.
There was more to this too.
Wait.
Let me find the full video.
I recorded a video where I literally showed the entire stadium.
And... Oh my god.
Did I...
Oh.
There it is.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
That's how packed it was.
Okay.
So...
Let me download this real quick.
And show you guys how packed the fucking stadium was.
It was actually crazy.
Um... Is this the media?
Okay.
Do I have a media source that I can use without having to worry about...
No.
I don't know!
I don't have... Okay.
Okay.
It might be really... Okay.
Actually, I'm going to use the music one.
Alright.
I'm going to use the music one because I don't want to blow your ears out here.
Okay.
Uh... Wait.
Is this the right one that I want to show?
I want to be sure.
Uh...
Let me double check real quick.
That this is the right one I want to show.
Wait.
Oh, you guys hear that?
I don't even know you guys hear that.
But look at this.
Oh my god.
Look at this.
It's crazy.
That's how many people there were on the last day.
Look at that.
It was literally sold out.
That was how many...
Yeah.
That was how many people there were there.
It was sold out and everything.
It was crazy.
That's why I was like, It's so loud.
I was like, It's so loud.
It was actually a sold out show.
And then...
And I was just like, It's so loud.
I was not ready for how loud it was.
I was not ready.
But yes, I would have to wear my earphones because of how loud it was in the stadium.
Just so I could watch it.
Because it was just a lot.
It was so much.
It was too much.
Let me show you guys where I busted the guy that was on a date.
Remember what I told you guys?
Oh my god.
One of the staff members caught him on a date because I was at a parfait shop!
Wow!
Look at that!
I was eating my parfait when I...
I'm not a stalker!
I'm not a stalker, okay?
I was literally...
I wanted parfait.
I just wanted parfait.
That doesn't make me a stalker.
I just wanted parfait!
Is that too much to ask for?
It's just a coincidence that they were on a date.
And also, look at these.
I bought these.
Aren't these cute?
They're so cute.
Okay, I just realized.
I just realized there was a tiny reflection there, so you're just gonna see the head.
You're just gonna see the head.
It's a very blurry reflection, but I'm not taking any risk here.
I'm not taking any risk.
Why?
Because I thought it was cute!
Okay, what else?
Oh my god, I want to unpack my suitcase to show you guys stuff I bought, but it's a lot of stuff.
Maybe I'll do it next time.
Maybe I'll do it tomorrow.
Maybe I'll show you guys tomorrow, but there's a lot of stuff I want to show you guys.
Oh!
Um, so like...
Uh...
There's something I actually wanted to show a photo of.
Let me see if I can find it.
Uh...
Oh yeah!
Let me see if I can find it real quick.
Uh...
Where is it?
Oh yeah, also like...
Let me show you guys this photo.
Because I thought it was silly.
I thought it was really silly.
Um...
I drank melon soda in a beer mug.
They just gave me melon soda in a beer mug.
I was like, nice.
My melon soda.
I thought it was really cute.
Um...
What did I want to show you guys again?
Oh fuck.
What was it?
Oh no!
I forgot what it was.
No!
Ah!
Oh no.
What was it?
I really wanted to show you guys something, but I forgot what it was on my mind.
Ah!
It was on my mind!
Oh yeah, here's a risky photo again.
Oh my god, fucking...
What was wrong with me?
What's wrong with you, Doki?
What the fuck is wrong with you?
They'll never know.
They'll never fucking know.
Living on the edge.
How would they know?
How would they know it's me?
There it is.
The front entrance of the ALGS championship area.
How would they know?
The riskiest bird out there.
Okay, wait, wait.
I'm going to be buffering for a bit.
So, if you guys didn't know, players, staff, and coaches at the Sapporo ALGS receive... I didn't take a picture of this because I stole this off of Twitter.
But I have it.
So, wait, let me see if I can find a photo.
Because I stole this off of Twitter and was like, can I get this?
So, like, this isn't a photo I took of it, but I want to show you guys.
I want to show it to you guys.
Oh, this isn't my photo.
I literally stole this off of the internet.
Okay, let me see.
I'm going to...
save this photo real quick.
So, it's actually really cool.
And I thought it was so cool, and that's why I requested if I could have it.
If I could have one as well as like a souvenir.
So, let me show this real quick.
So, this is not my photo, but I stole this off the internet.
But it's basically the... if you guys don't know, Sapporo slash Hokkaido is known for this specific chocolate treat.
And it's like the really flat one.
You know the dark blue packaging one for it?
You guys know this.
If you're in Japan, you know exactly what this chocolate brand is.
And it's like super...
really famous in Japan.
And they did a special promotion with Apex and ALGS.
And...
So, I saw this and I was like...
So, every player, staff and coach gets this.
So, I heard about it.
You know, cause I was like...
Cause players were there early.
Because they have to like adjust the jet lag and everything.
And then so, I messaged the Apex staff members...
And be like, can I get one?
It's gonna be my first LAN.
They said no.
They said...
And they're like, sorry, this is reserved for the players and the staff and the coaches.
So I was like, okay.
They're like, but we hope you enjoy your time at LGS.
I was like, I guess.
No, I didn't steal it!
So, I begged.
No, I didn't beg, guys.
I didn't beg.
I asked if like, you know, with my connections of people that were...
Of my connections to the players, the staff members, the people who have like, high authority.
Who may or may not be casting and stuff like that.
And be like, can you guys get me one of them?
And then they got me the chocolate bar.
Like, they got me one of them.
And I also got an LGS mug.
So, I got it!
That's right!
I got it!
See me, see this on eBay.
No, I'm not gonna sell it.
I'm pretty sure it could go for like, a lot of money.
Connections, just for fun.
But look, it has... Look at that, it has Apex Legends on it.
Look at that, it's so unique.
It's so unique, it has the Apex Legends on it.
Look at that.
I also got an ALGS mug too, like for free as well.
I got it for free!
So, yeah, I was super happy about it too.
You know what?
No, I... You know what, fuck it.
I'm gonna get my suitcase in here and start taking pictures.
Give me a sec.
Guys, you can hear me.
I'm gonna bring my suitcase.
I wanna show you guys some of the stuff I got.
Give me a sec.
Alright, you're just gonna hear me grab my suitcase.
Alright.
I didn't unpack anything.
I
have two things that's in front of me that I can show.
Alright.
Let's see.
Oh, I also... Oh my god, I wanna show this!
Okay, I'll just show you guys this.
That's all I'm gonna show you guys.
I gave up.
I looked in my suitcase and I was like, I have no room.
I was literally... I was like, I can do this.
And then I looked at it and I was like, I have no room for this.
I have no room.
I have no room to unpack this.
Okay, I'm gonna be buffering.
I'll take a picture of what I got.
Also, I realized I'll have to take pictures and stuff, so...
I bought this.
Because, like, okay, I don't know if you guys know about it, but...
Oh, I can't show you guys the... I'll show you guys the Cappy hat another time.
I bought a hat that looks like Cappy that basically looks like my hat if you think about it.
And... Oh, I forgot to send the picture to myself.
I was like, I took the picture and now I open...
Now I open the box and I was like, wait, I forgot to...
I forgot to send this picture.
Okay.
Let me see.
Where's the picture?
I bought this snack because I thought...
So you guys didn't know, in Sapporo and Hokkaido, when they're like...
Oh my gosh, whoops.
Also, I need to buy a new mousepad.
My new Artisan mousepad because...
That shit is getting...
It's, like, falling apart right now.
Artisan mousepads, please sponsor me.
But, like...
It's not a dick, but...
That's my phone.
So, like, I'm gonna open it.
I'm sad that I'm gonna destroy the packaging.
But they're known for their little snowbird.
Like the... I don't know what they're called.
The little birdies that they have.
But they're known for it.
And...
Yeah, and it's square.
I might need to see a doctor.
Okay.
What the fuck?!
The ribbon!
No!
Oh, wait, that's so cute!
Oh my god!
Okay, I got a little sad.
Because, like, I was like...
Oh, this packaging is so cute.
And then I opened it.
And then I was like...
No!
It's just yellow!
And then I opened the box.
And I was like...
Oh, okay, there we go.
Never mind.
It's okay.
But, like, this is what I...
When I opened it, I was like...
No!
No, my beautiful packaging!
But I'll show you why I was, like, a bit sad earlier.
And I opened the box.
I was like...
Okay, I can deal with that.
Because I wanted to try it out.
So...
Oh, wait, did I not save it?
Oh, I didn't save it.
Okay.
So, and then, like, I opened it.
And then I was like...
No, why is the box just yellow?!
So, obviously, I was, like, freaking out.
And I was like...
Why is the box just yellow?!
I thought underneath would be the same thing!
But then I opened the box.
And then the birds were there.
And I was like...
Okay, I'm fine.
That's okay.
It's alright.
I'm okay now.
I was like...
It's alright.
I'm okay now.
I'm gonna try this out.
There's this.
I'm gonna try it.
Panic cops almost lost my cool there.
I was like...
No!
I literally bought it because the packaging was so cute!
It was so cute.
I was like...
I destroyed it on stream!
Oh, it's so sad.
It's so sad.
It's pretty good.
I like it.
Hmm.
And I bought it for the birds!
Bought it specifically for the birds.
I'm sad I didn't buy like a little bird plushie just for like Hokkaido.
Because like I said, they're like known for...
They're known for like...
That's like their bird mascot.
So I thought it was super cute.
But yeah.
You know what?
I did say I'm not gonna travel for a long time.
But I think this year I'm definitely gonna go back to Hong Kong.
At one point.
Because I really...
I do miss...
I miss Hong Kong.
I miss like eating food there and just exploring the places.
But I...
Oh man.
I won't go there during the fall or the winter.
I am not going back there in the summer though.
I'm sorry.
It's like...
I'm not going back there during the summer.
I'm gonna make sure the mosquitoes are fucking dead.
By the time I go back.
I need a...
I need a mixture.
And those fucking mosquitoes are hibernating.
I can't go back during the summer.
How hot does it get there?
Think hot and then times 10.
Like...
So...
I think that's gonna be my next vacation.
I'd love to...
I'd love to go back there.
This year.
Because I haven't been back there for like...
I think like...
5 plus years.
It's been 5 plus years since I've been back.
It was pre...
Pre-COVID.
And then plus...
2 to 3 more years.
I think that...
Oh my god.
That's a long time ago.
I've been back there for a very long time.
Yeah.
Like plus 2 years pre-COVID.
And then 2 years.
Plus 2 more years.
So it's been...
It's been a very very long time since I've been back to Hong Kong.
So I really would like to go back.
For a little bit.
For a vacation.
But I definitely won't be traveling for a while.
Because like I said.
I'm very traveled though.
I think like...
This year.
I've traveled so much.
Like last year.
Sorry.
Last year I've definitely traveled more than I expected to.
Last year.
So I'm definitely gonna...
I wanna...
Also I need to recuperate my finances too.
I need to recuperate my finances after Japan.
Like post-Japan actually fucked me up.
We're gonna deal with that first.
Yeah.
What else did I wanna say?
Oh my god.
There's something I wanna...
There's something I really wanna say.
But I forgot again.
Ah!
My brain!
Oh my god.
Why?
I'm...
Oh my god.
I'm going to dementia.
Oh no.
Oh yeah.
One of my friends.
One of my friends was thinking about going to...
Was doing like a cruise to Asia.
Around Asia.
And they were asking me about like Hong Kong and stuff.
They're like...
Oh man, I really wanna go to Hong Kong and Disneyland.
And I was like...
Oh, you're gonna finish it in like less than...
You're gonna finish it within like...
I think you can finish it within half a day.
And then my friend was like...
There's no way.
It's Disneyland.
And I was like...
No, it's small.
I was like...
Oh, you don't understand.
Hong Kong is all about things being compact and small.
And Hong Kong Disneyland is small.
Yeah.
You can literally...
For the...
You might...
People who might go to Disneyland and other places are not used to the fact of how small Hong Kong Disneyland is.
I was like, you should go to Ocean Park.
I was like...
I straight up told him.
No, I did.
I was like...
No, you should go to Ocean Park if you're gonna wanna go to an amusement park.
Cause like Ocean Park is a lot bigger.
And it's also like a lot better.
And there's pandas too.
And then so I was like...
No, you should go to Ocean Park.
It's actually like a more fun experience.
Because it's an actual amusement park.
I'm sorry.
Like...
Hong Kong Disneyland is so fucking...
I remember...
I can finish Hong Kong Disneyland in four hours.
Like...
I was like...
You can...
That's...
You can go from one side to the other side within like 15 minutes.
I swear to god.
If you walk from one end of the park to the next, it would take you 15 minutes, guys.
15 to 20 minutes.
Just to get from one side to the other.
And...
Yeah.
And then like...
So I was like...
But the lines.
There's fast passes in Hong...
I don't know if they like changed it.
But like...
The fast passes for Hong Kong Disneyland is so fucking fast.
Like...
It's so fast.
Like you don't even have to worry about lines.
Like you just get the fast pass and you're fucking set to go.
Like...
I heard they added a new...
The new frozen park though.
So like maybe it's a little bigger now.
But it's just...
So like...
It's like...
Yeah, so...
They're like...
Wait, is it really?
I was like...
No.
I swear.
If you're gonna...
Don't plan your whole day around Disneyland.
You're gonna fit...
You don't need a...
You don't need to plan your whole day around that.
But yeah.
I wanna go to Shanghai Disneyland.
Yeah.
Shanghai Disneyland looks...
I feel like...
I feel like Shanghai Disneyland had so many like...
Cooler upgrades.
Versus like the Disneyland's around the world.
Because their animatronics seem like so much like...
I guess because they're more updated animatronics.
But I heard...
I heard Shanghai Disneyland is like really really good as well.
Also they have more land.
Like...
It's not our...
It's not like Hong Kong's fault.
You know like...
We have very limited land.
Like...
Shanghai has a lot more land for their parks.
Hong Kong Disneyland...
We're like...
Struggling to figure out where to put the next thing.
Yeah.
But yeah, that's...
I guess I'm...
I think like...
I would love to go back to Ocean Park though.
I don't wanna go back to Disneyland again.
But yeah, I...
Last time I went to Ocean Park was like...
For my...
Birthday when I was really young.
So...
I'd love to go back to Ocean Park.
And honestly, I just wanna go back to Hong Kong for food.
Like...
Food and the pop-up shops.
Oh my god.
What was that place called?
This is one of my favorite malls.
It's like next to the ocean.
Cause it's like...
Ginormous.
And they have like the best pop-up shops.
Was it Ocean Center?
Oh my god.
Wait, is it?
Is it Ocean Center?
I don't remember.
Okay, it's like next to the ocean.
Wait, is it?
I don't remember if it is.
Okay, Hong.
It's like one of my favorite malls.
Cause like...
That's where the giant duck was.
Like...
I don't know if anybody remembers.
But there was a...
There was like a giant...
There was at one point in Hong Kong.
They had a giant fucking inflatable duck.
Like next to that mall.
And then it got...
And then it deflated.
I don't know if it was...
I don't remember where.
Oh, is it Harbor City?
Oh my god.
I love Harbor City!
The Harbor City has some of the best pop-up shops ever.
Alright, if you guys ever want to tour...
Like be a tourist.
And be a tourist in Hong Kong.
Harbor City is such a great mall.
Because like...
They have really cool like pop-up shops too.
Because at one time they had Neko Atsume.
Neko Atsume pop-up shop.
And...
And like...
It was like one of my favorite...
They always have really cool pop-up shops.
Oh my god.
Okay, I remember.
Cause I was like thinking about like...
I would always go there for like HMV too.
Cause back then they had a really big HMV store.
And like...
Oh my god.
You know what's funny?
Okay.
I was like debating if I should tell this story.
Because it's like...
Okay, I just thought it was funny.
But also like...
I was like...
What the fuck is happening?
Oh my god.
But I'll tell the story really quick.
Like...
This story.
There's no like...
Ill-intentions.
I just thought it was funny.
Cause I told my friends.
And they were like...
What the fuck?
So...
I was at...
When I was in Japan.
Um...
I saw...
I went to the HMV in Japan.
And then I was like...
Is that merch of me?
Obviously not me.
But like...
Me?
I was like...
It's...
It's been a year.
I don't get revenue off of that.
I don't get any royalties off of that.
And then I was like...
And then I told my friends.
I was like...
Is it pre-owned?
And I was like...
No, it's new.
I was like...
I thought these were sold out.
And they were like...
I was just like...
I was like...
My friend is like...
Wait, what?
I was like...
Yes.
I saw like plushies and everything.
And I was like...
I was like...
They're like...
It's been a year.
And I was like...
I was like...
No.
I was so surprised.
I was not expecting it.
I don't get like...
I don't get like profit off of that by the way.
Because I got...
You know.
So, it was just, it was so funny.
I was like, what the fuck is up?
It was so funny.
I just took a picture of it too.
I was like, bro, what the fuck, that's me!
That's me in Japan!
Oh my god.
Um, um, um, but yeah, I just thought, I just thought it was so funny.
I debated about telling the story, but I was like, fuck it.
Cause I was thinking, cause I saw this at an HMV too.
Um, um, no, no, it's an official, they're, they're like, it's not third Friday, they're an official, like they're official seller for the merch.
So I just, I was like, why am I, oh my god.
Um, yeah, yeah, anyway.
But like I said, I would, oh my gosh, there's so many places.
I'm just like thinking back, there's like so many places I would love to go when I visit Hong Kong again.
But yeah, I wish I could.
I wish I, oh my gosh.
The only thing I sort of wish, um, I wish AOGS wasn't around that time, is that I really wanted to go to like a Lunar New Year festival, um, in my city.
I just, cause like, I think what I missed, oh my god, I missed the lion dances, the, the lion dances and, uh, uh, uh, and like all the, like, just like, you know, just the things you can do during like Lunar New Year festivals.
And ah, I, I wish, I really, cause I was gonna go to one of them.
Um, I was gonna go to one of them if AOGS wasn't around that time.
Yeah, I was, I was like, I was like, ah man, and I found it.
I was like, wait, it happens at the same time.
Ah, I couldn't, I couldn't go.
I was like a little bit upset about that.
Um, but maybe next year, maybe next year.
Obviously, there's no Lunar New Year festivals right now going on, cause like, I got, I was a little late.
Oh yeah, by the way, um, we are, um, this is for next, uh, well, we're gonna put this up soon when we revamp our store.
But if you guys didn't know, uh, we have, we're gonna have, obviously, like, you know, Lunar New Year's ending, but like, what's funny is that a lot of the people who receive Lunar New Year merch from last year are getting it before this Lunar New Year.
But like, if you guys didn't know, we're gonna have new Lunar New Year envelopes.
We actually have them produced already, so we actually have them on hand.
But I haven't put it up on the store yet, cause we're revamping the store at the moment.
So, um, these are the new envelopes that, uh, we actually have already made.
So like, we actually could be sending them out whenever they're purchased.
Um, but yes, um, we're gonna have new Lunar New Year envelopes.
Um, uh, but it's not gonna be, I'm not gonna be selling them this month.
Um, we're gonna wait until the store gets revamped by our new distributor.
Uh, so yeah, they're so cute.
I showed these before, but I wanted to show you guys today again because it's, uh, uh, uh, you know, just cause it's Lunar New Year.
No, the envelopes aren't limited.
Um, we're gonna restock the old envelopes too.
So the envelopes will not be limited at all.
Uh, Gus, thank you for this Magenta Supa.
Thank you, thank you.
It's love hearing you find it funny after one year after that.
Thank you for the Magenta Supa.
Thank you, thank you.
I was just surprised, dude.
I was like, I was like, you know, after all of that, why would you still sell?
I guess, you know, money.
Cause like, they still have like stock remaining or some shit, but I was just like, why is it still here?
Like, um, but, um, one of my friends was like, they should have destroyed the stock.
I was like, I don't know.
I was like, it seems like a waste, so I get that.
Um, I just thought it was funny.
Yeah, no, my friend was like, burn it.
Why didn't they just burn it all?
And I was like, what the, chill.
Just put it in a grinder.
Like, that would be so, honestly, it would have been very therapeutic if you could just, you know, just grind them up.
But yeah, so yeah, I wish I could show you guys more photos.
I'm so dumb.
I should have just taken more photos of like, uh, oh yeah.
Oh, I took photos of this.
Wait, I can show you guys this.
I can show you guys this.
So, like, at ALGS, they had a thing where, um, oh, they had Trolloc, yeah.
They had a thing where they actually had, like, um, replicas, life-size replicas of the Heirlooms.
So, obviously, I took a picture of Mirage.
So, they had, like, the life-size replicas of all the Heirlooms from Apex Legends, and I thought, that is really neat.
I took a picture of Mirage because, obviously, I wouldn't... I took a picture of all of them, but then there's reflections, so I was like, I don't know.
I don't know if I was showing those.
But, yeah, it was like, there was a lot of them, too, so I just wanted to show... Oh, yeah, and then there's... Oh, and then there's these guys.
These guys doing, like, ice sculptures.
I was not stalking them, by the way.
I legitimately... Look at them!
They were doing their ice sculptures.
So, this was pre... before they were finished with them.
So, if you guys didn't know, Hokkaido is known for their... or Sapporo is known for their, like, ice festivals and, like, ice sculptures.
And I thought it was really cool to see them, like, actually carve stuff out in ice.
Really cool.
I had... It was so cool, like, showing... Like, just seeing them... Why do you keep repeating?
Because I want you guys to know I'm not a stalker!
I need you guys to know I'm not a stalker.
I just... I just wanted to take a picture of them carving out ice sculptures.
I swear to God.
Oh, yeah.
There's a team that won... There's a team that won ALGS and the people are, like, yelling about how, like, they don't deserve to... I don't know.
The newest, like, drama about Apex is that people are yelling at how they shouldn't have won the LAN thing because the meta was so boring that...
But, yeah, I thought it was cool because it was, like, little fireworks and stuff.
Who won?
Go next.
And then you guys are, like, who exactly?
If you're, like, who exactly?
And that's why there's drama right now.
But why?
Why did they win?
But I thought it was cool.
And then let's see what our photos did.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
I'll show you guys.
Here's another... Here's another living on the edge photo.
Wait, did I not save it?
Where's the... Oh, there it is.
Here's another one.
I always... I use a dragoon.
I always use a dragoon for these photos because, like, I feel like if I use, like, anything else that's not a dragoon, then, like, that's way too risky.
Like, at least a dragoon, people would just think, like, oh, you know, like, it's just a bird, you know?
I was just like, like, it's less obvious.
It's less obvious when I'm in the public, okay?
So that's what I mean, like, yeah, like, it's just... They'll just think it's, like, a yellow bird.
And so then I... So I was just like, yeah, so this was the ending of the tournament.
This was the ending of the tournament, and so it was, like, I just took a picture and was like, whoa, there you guys are.
There you guys are.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Seek help, Doki!
I don't need help!
I don't need a therapist!
Oh, no, okay.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Liz, thank you for the superchat.
No!
How did you lose it?
Like, wait, what?
Asahi, I win you.
You deserve to know what happened.
Wait, how did you lose it?
How is that possible?
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Wait a minute.
Wait, explain.
Explain.
How could that... How could they have lost it?
We need to know the story.
We need to know.
Oh, no!
My buff teddy bear!
Did you report it to the cops?
Oh, my God.
Did the police know?
How could this have happened?
Somebody called 911!
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Liz, we gotta report a missing... We gotta file a missing person report!
This is important.
This is about how do I file a missing person report.
Okay.
Alright.
Yeah, how do you lose a 15-inch slushie?
I know, that's what I was thinking, too.
How do you lose that?
He's a fucking tank.
He's a fucking tank!
He's bigger than my cat robot, Fuddly!
Where is he?
Bring him home.
Guys, we gotta start a hashtag.
Oh, my God.
This is like a national emergency now.
Alright.
Wow.
Oh, my God.
I've been talking for two hours.
Anyway, guys, I'm gonna call it here.
I had a great time hanging out with everybody.
I hope you guys had a great time hanging out with me today.
I hope you guys enjoyed the photos.
I'll show more photos tomorrow.
Before my, like, you know, before I play Apex.
I'll show more photos tomorrow for everybody.
So, like, of things I got and stuff.
But I had a great time talking to everyone.
As always, everybody...
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed, cause you deserve it.
But, yeah, definitely, like...
We're going back to our regular scheduled content starting today.
So, like, no more vacation and stuff like that.
So, it's gonna...
After that, we'll be fine.
It's back to regular content.
Anyway, guys, as always, I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.
I also forgot to buy my merch.
I keep forgetting to show it, guys.
Please, there's only two weeks left for pajamas.
Bye.